before the crew is hired before the
actors are cast before the set to build
to the cameras roll there's just the
writer and that spark the anonymous
moment of inspiration that gives first
light to a story and without that moment
without the talent of these writers we
would have nothing to celebrate tonight
so here are the nominees for Best
Adapted Screenplay Jason hall for
American sniper based on the book by
Chris Kyle with Scott McEwan and Jim
DeFelice
Graham Moore for the imitation game
based on the book Alan Turing the Enigma
by Andrew Hodges Paul Thomas Anderson
for inherent vice based on the novel by
Thomas Pynchon Anthony McCartan for the
theory of everything
based on the book traveling to infinity
my life with Stephen by Jane Hawking
Damien Chazelle for whiplash based on
the short film whiplash and the Oscar
goes to Graham Moore the imitation game
first Oscar and we know
I anymore
thank you so much to the Academy and to
Oprah for this I need to shower my love
and kisses on everyone who's a part of
our imitation game family Morton Norah
Ito Teddy Kyra Benedict Billy
Alexandra our entire cast Maria is back
there's more I love you guys so much
thank you for this film I'm so indebted
to for it um so here's here's the thing
um Alan Turing never got to stand on a
stage like this and look out at all of
these disconcertingly attractive faces
and I do and that's the most unfair
thing I think I've ever heard
so in this brief time here what I want
to use it to do is to say this um when I
was 16 years old I tried to kill myself
because I felt weird and I felt
different and I felt like I did not
belong and now I'm standing here and so
I would like for this moment to be for
that kid out there who feels like she's
weird or she's different or she doesn't
fit in anywhere yes you do I promise you
do you do stay weird stay different and
then when it's your turn and you are
standing on the stage please pass the
same message to a next person who comes
along give you so much